[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link yeah you got to hit that
consonant yeah this this morning we do
Oh
what what are you clicking for you gotta
tell them that it's the morning again
well yeah I can just look at your face I
can't there's no denying it I get out of
it we listening to your face but now
that we've done one year biscuit in the
morning I think at this point we should
just make people guess by looking at the
face maybe I'm faking it
maybe I'm throwing them for a loop yeah
I can have morning face at night I've
done that before us it's a get snap snap
face this week at the roundtable of dim
lighting we're gonna share some personal
experiences I think there might be some
some deep introspection I don't I think
we're at risk of there being a point
where this gets sad based on something
I've got inside my own heart okay oh
gosh here's here's the deal yeah you're
already using the word heart as of not
talking about the anatomy or you're
talking about it in the the emotional
sense I know I'm just warning you people
because technically your heart doesn't
actually hold any thoughts I mean it's
just a muscle that pumps your blood I
mean I hate to burst your bubbles for
everybody but that's all happen in your
freakin brain and anatomically speaking
I don't have a bubble to burst
so bar saw you I just gotta maintain the
balance here you mean making light of
the fact that I said I'm gonna cry no
listen man I mean I know what we're
talking about so I might never know
what's gonna here is the deal as face as
of this current conversation the moment
of recording this I am 39 years old as
of the initial release of this podcast
in its audio form I am 39 years old but
as of June 1st 2018 I become 14 and I've
already celebrated in a huge way in
party form and I want to tell you all
about that party and then I want
transition into just an analysis of of
our own aging because buddy I'm joining
you in the boat in the forty boat I'm
about to get up hey did you just burn
yourself on teeth you're like an old man
see I can't even I can't even I can't
drink tea anymore
you got to put an ice cube in your tea I
feel like Jim Baker eating potato soup
which incidentally I watched a crap-ton
of last night oh you did
because RuPaul actually posted the very
best of Jim Baker it was a compilation
Twitter on Twitter but it was a YouTube
video and I just said hey RuPaul edit
this thing no Paul has time to it was a
super deluxe video it was not yeah I
mean it was one that I had seen all the
pieces before but it was the very best
and it included that that's good good
moment which we put in the episode where
we tasted the Jim Baker bucket um yeah
we did is that why you got such snap
face this morning cuz you stayed up late
watching a Jim Baker bucket it's only a
16 minute clip so no I've already
internet I've already been to the gym
I've been in a steam room with several
other naked fellows okay I mean I'm I'm
up man it's just my face I guess my face
you know what I think maybe in the same
way that there were people I saw you saw
as well comment on the Internet when you
asked let us know what you think about
us recording in the morning Allah fear
Allah I can definitely notice it's
different
well I doubt that they can notice it's
different that's my personal opinion is
we suggested that it was my friend and
then the power of suggestion and they
started to think that they were picking
up on different things I think that my
morning face is if I if it was if it was
11 p.m. right now you'd be like you look
tired man you just woke up and if it was
the middle of day you'd be like you look
normal I hide that that's my thought on
you think oh no I thought you were gonna
say in the middle of the day I was gonna
say he looked tired
no milla day
I would be what you expect which is
middle of the day face which is just
normal so your peak Rhett face at noon
is what you're saying I'm saying it's
always the same that's not what I heard
no not right I'm saying it right now
having been through the things that I've
been through today
I can you said you should have seen fit
I still have what you would consider
morning face mm-hmm two hours ago I
definitely had morning face but I got
steamed face now oh well I guess they're
they're they're easily mistaken for one
another I mean do I look like I have a
nap face no because I don't let the
power of suggestion and the environment
influence my opinions I'm a perfectly
rational being not even your your own
suggestion I don't mean to insult you
ear biscuit ear listener but I do feel
like when we said that and I guess it
was the last episode talking about in
the morning was that the last one with
it whenever it was it doesn't matter we
were just kind of planting something so
that then you can feel like you were
noticing something I mean three ago
three ago we go we're still waking out
we been doing some steam room and
there's an art to internat Ament where
you you you can plant something in a
video that people will feel smart for
noticing and then commenting on but
really we're the smart ones were putting
in individual yeah we're the smart one
we wanted you to talk about how
different it was in the morning if he
thought that it was better okay I'm sure
it was different I'm just being fiscally
backtrack a little bit
I don't want to hurt your feelings I'm
sure it was different but it's getting
old and crotchety at least a person
almost 40 at least a percentage of you
definitely said something just because
we said we gave you the opportunity to
say it and that's that's a that's a good
thing because that's how the world works
we're pulling the curtain back you're
seeing our you're seeing our bare
bottoms in the hospital that it's not a
curtain well there is a curtain and then
is there's a gallon a gown we're pulling
the gown back because we don't hold
anything back from you because that
that's the new me that's the middle-aged
me
we should we can get into this but I
mean forties not meant the middle of my
age I aspire statistically yeah speaking
it probably is I'm not gonna what
statistically live past 80 what is the
average life expectancy of a man in
America could somebody look that up I
would guess that it is 86 no I would say
82 max ooh and I would say probably 79 I
think maybe a woman is 82 if it's less
than 80 lie no don't like tell us the
truth
78 oh dang I was classy at 79 at 70
points what 78574 oh gosh yeah dude I've
already past middle age I didn't even
know yeah yeah your pet I did that a
year ago exactly that's what I call over
the hill man now I do think it means
something different but this is what I
want to get into last night we're gonna
talk let's not get into it yeah we're
gonna talk about getting old let's start
buckle up let's start with a party man
because I feel like I owe it to you to
give a complete play-by-play of my party
because a we did that with your party
Rhett yeah yeah yeah and I in it and be
you you weren't invited so this is my
way of including you even though you
weren't invited or you know what maybe
you're one of the people that was
invited and you know you'll know when
I'm lying about something embellishing
to make my party seem good of course
you're here for that I I'm here for that
um I need a t-shirt that says that
thanks for coming to my party right
you're welcome when you walked in on so
relieved
yeah yeah that you sure I almost didn't
go you thinking about it last minute
we're like should we what were you
thinking about doing I was gonna watch
out Paulo 1300 ghin yeah it's a good
movie I was like aids you know you know
you know you're gonna get a good
satisfying experience but with the party
any but you're like do you experience an
anxiety when going to a party like
anybody's party I always have a tinge of
anxiety when I go into maybe it's just
any sort of I mean I go to I experienced
this you
any I think I experience a tinge of
anxiety if I'm in any environment that
is not 100% familiar to me okay
it's good that you're admitting that
just just joking okay Christie turned 40
on May 13th there's like a there's a
two-week gap there where she's older
than me I mean she's always constantly
older than me and I do point that out to
her at in strategic moments older women
make beautiful lovers is the country
song that's a good country song but
never is it more obvious in the two
weeks when she's 40 and I'm not right
and we've you know we planned our party
smack-dab in the middle and I mean we
had it into in plaintive the party we
really had to run interference with what
you what you did you know I think we
talked about this in terms of like you
had a grand party man so I mean another
bar rule it was you set the bar really
high and honestly I had multiple
conversations with Christie in the
privacy of our own zone where I was like
let's not have a party yep like and it
wasn't I mean it wasn't like I don't
think I can top retz party I mean
Christie did say something like that
don't compare don't compare
you you don't have to think like that
you don't have to compare your you're
our party to Rhett's party is a good
party but it's just not a it's not a
healthy path but you're gonna you were
gonna let that keep you having a party
now it was just one factor I think I
mean I did have it probably the greatest
birthday party ever
haha but that did I shouldn't you stop
you from trying in general I mean even
like I said even going to a party
there's like a level of anxiety that
maybe every most people will experience
like what's this gonna be like stepping
into this thing but then when you're in
charge of it I mean it seems like
there's more pressure I mean it
certainly didn't take any pressure away
to have experienced your party but
Chrissie
Christie really wanted a party and I
came around I was more than happy to be
a part of I was like but we got it okay
I want there to be something I wanted
there to be an activity so we ultimately
decided that we were going to have a
bowling party yeah and we found this
amazing venue the oldest bowling alley
in the city of Los Angeles which is one
of the oldest cities in the world I
don't know if you knew that no I did not
know the second part I don't know I need
to wiki that but the first part is to
Highland Park Bowl super cool menu right
like we had never been there but we
visit it in order to see I could
describe the place just so you don't
seem to like a braggy daddy okay yo I
didn't build it I didn't renovate it but
this place was it is the oldest bowling
alley in LA very very very cool and like
stepping into a bowling alley from a
time gone by so like you got this like
row a prohibition-era you like Spears
there's a bar on each side and then
there's the the lanes and they've got
they're doing a lot of things to kind of
establish the vibe right this is a
hipster bowling place very cool place
all the bowling balls are black there's
you know you know pink balls here no
blue balls either it's just I think all
black balls which it was an aesthetic
choice not a functional makes it a
little difficult to remember which ball
is yours but but it's worth the cool
factor and the lanes not only look
amazingly vintage but then the hole is
$90 plays 91 years old built in 1927
that the mechanism the mechanism in the
very back you know when you win it when
you bowl knock down the pins and then
the mechanism the robot thingy picks up
the pins sorts them all out and put some
back down looks like that's the ball on
punk it's all like a steampunk set oh
gosh I'm not gonna reward it's all
exposed like it's real inner workings of
it nothing's covered like a napkin
I don't want use your sleeve I don't
want to lead Newton's signature to go
away use that right there or Lindsey
stir
oh I was gonna let you use my jacket
sleeve anyway yeah it was a super super
cool place they have a a pizza oven so
they're like making some good people the
food was incredible and just as our book
dictated there will be meatballs at the
party well there was meatballs at the
party it was that a special request
because of our book or they just that's
something they do it's something they
offer and I was like they were like we
can have meatballs I was like there will
be meatballs they're spicy meatballs
there was so big though I don't think we
could have played hide the meatball I
didn't even think about that cutting
ball because I was throwing the ball in
balls I actually didn't get to eat a
meatball I mean so there was like I
don't know maybe 120 of our friends and
some the mythical crew members were also
there I consider friends and in the
party zone not co-workers for all
friends in the party zone and Christine
are Ming Lionel Richie and then yeah you
said I should get Lionel Richie but we
didn't do that we had a DJ and I made a
playlist which I steered clear of Yacht
rock even though that is my one of my
favorite genres of music because you had
the the the the gold standard of Yacht
rock cover bands at your party so what
did I just hear clear that what did you
play it was late 70s early 80s so around
the time that we were born soul and funk
music but but the bowling alley so loud
that it just kind of all blends together
it wasn't it didn't register really I
didn't want the music too loud so that
you couldn't talk with you people
you know the DJ feel emasculated bye-bye
why about that request I I paid him so
he could feel any way he wants if you
know but I think I think DJ's get off on
being being listened to playing the
music so I didn't ask you can't play not
have a meaningful conversation with
anyone I couldn't tell and I didn't care
he did a great job and I don't think he
was upset so it was a cool spot
Christine I had matching bowling shirts
I don't know if you noticed
I did it with your names on him and of
course we also have matching bowling
shirts when we did the fire bowling but
you wore yours
and of course I have to wear it Jesse
could have worn mine and you could have
she Jesse got her own she got her off
she went off on her own and got her own
bowling shirt in the back we tried
really hard to find something to put on
the back of the shirt for me and Christy
and we landed on striking while we're
still hot where'd you get that I think
that Jesse came up with my wife cuz I
was like she's very good she loves that
she's like yeah there was a text thread
so he's really good at slogan let's see
cuz I wanted it to be something that was
lame like bolvar the hill I think here's
what I came up with a combination of
bowling and over the hill if it's not
clear Christy didn't like that so it did
it well striking while we're still hot
they don't want to focus on and it was a
bowling ball and there was flames the
back end of the hill they wanted to
focus on the fact that we're still good
look at ya and then I had I requested
that Christy shirt also have you know
those the silhouette of the women that
are on the mud flaps of Briggs
of course I'm good I wanted her down the
back of my sedan I wanted her to put
those on the collar a pair of truck nuts
the lapel of her bowling shirt and when
she nixed that idea I put it on my
bowling shirt because I wanted it to
represent her on her own shirt and I was
going to have the man version on my own
and when we started looking into the man
version of mudflap silhouettes that's
very problematic right because what can
you emphasize right so I have the woman
on mine and then I we had our names
embroidered no link I noticed a woman I
didn't I didn't ask any questions about
it it's a it's Christy its Christy
silhouette she's still hot and and my
name said link and underneath it said 40
years old because I'm like I'm an
illness Christy also didn't want her
does it say 40 years old but it said 40
on the lapel these are the type of
things that you get into the minutia of
planning a party and that's when I'm
like oh my gosh it's it's so much
there's so much effort and in
in planning in details and then it's
very overwhelming for me I think the
thing that I learned was it was it was a
great party and I feel like I would have
had so much more fun if everything was
the exact same except it being my party
I think that's my problem is that it I
feel like I told Chrissy somewhere in
the middle cause we're like mingling and
talking with our Emily man it feels like
a wedding reception I'm like not getting
to eat anything and I'm like talking
everybody and it's you know it's it's
becoming a blur whereas if you just
attend a party mission number one is
just to have fun
you know but when you're in charge of it
mission number one is that at least in
my mind and I couldn't check out from
this is making sure everybody else was
having fun and Who am I kidding they
were it wasn't up to me I mean you set
the stage and then hey we're freakin
bowling in this amazing place we got
pizza and you got bowling shirt I think
I think I don't know when this happened
definitely in the past like two years
I've experienced a shift in recognizing
that I enjoy creating experiences for
people okay and while I completely
relate to what you were saying it's
difficult to enjoy anything that you've
placed difficult to enjoy a meal that
you cooked as someone who cares you know
I'll have like a bunch of people over
and like do a pork butt or something and
I enjoy food more if I go to a
restaurant than if I make it for myself
and for other people but I kind of shift
it to like oh all these people are
enjoying this and then you take a little
bit of the pressure off of yourself so
it's so I think that that my you think
you becoming one of a host my party I
was at when people kept coming up and
saying they were having a good time I
was having a good time
even though I was anxious about when
things are happening and write a thing
and then like the game night that we've
been doing yeah which I legitimately
been having a lot of fun personally but
the fact that people are enjoying it I'm
enjoying that vicariously I think that's
I think that's the the key to not being
anxious about something that your debt
at your own party it's like because
everybody did have a really good time I
almost had a great time because almost
was on the winning bowling oh thank you
he giving it away yeah he lost
well we had a bowling tournament and
Chrissy said okay we're gonna hop on the
mics and you can orient people to hell
this bowling tournaments gonna go might
well that means we need to make a speech
are you what she's like I'll talk first
and then you can do that my what I gotta
I gotta have my speech so like I worked
up a speech that I don't know if you
could tell by the execution of my speech
but well i f tit up man
well here's what i'll say when you in
the middle
you were you were talking in your like
he's talking about the bowling rules or
something that the way the tournament is
gonna work and then there was a pause it
was a little longer than I was
comfortable and then you were like f
what they say about being 40 and I was
like and what I thought was links got
something here like I know how your
brain works and so I was like right he's
going into he's got something he's
prepared something
but then he was trying to access
something that he had prepared but but
then but then it fizzled in you just had
like another sentence it fizzled and it
turning I mean it turned it to a
heartfelt thanks to all of my friends
for being there but he was the he was
here's what I wanted to do I wanted to I
want to say okay I'm gonna I'm gonna
start by saying something it's gonna get
everybody's attention we like what the
heck and this was it I was gonna say I
don't give a flying F what people say
about 40 and then I was gonna say I
can't even remember it right now I
should I had it on a card you know you
can't have it on a card
I don't give a flying F what people say
about 40 I think 40 is fabulous when
you're fortunate enough to have friends
like these stevia F's yeah alliteration
and then I was just gonna leave it at
that
oh that was all it was okay that was it
right okay I had planned just that and I
was gonna leave that because you know me
I like I ramble and it and things start
to fall apart the worst example of that
was my wedding rehearsal dinner that you
know we constantly make fun of me for
which I deserve it which is I went
around and started thinking every single
person that attended my personally
wedding they all got it like a
two-minute speech which which was
literally I mean two times 60 is 120
yeah there was two hours I mean it might
have been a 90-minute speech because
once I got into it I couldn't back out
and I'm like I'm not gonna make that
mistake I'm gonna have something quick
and it's gonna be about f's
okay all right yeah and then I I blew it
well I don't it doesn't matter I don't
think anybody other than yeah yeah yeah
you had something that you didn't fully
patch yeah yeah yeah the egg the egg
cracked on the floor but I scraped it up
and no one else cared that that's the
thing is like I started you know you
start to focus on things that don't
matter that much I just don't think I
don't think throwing parties is for me
man
just for my personal enjoyment well next
time you should you should plan my
parties but but I think it's just a
shift in a shift in mentality because
well I mean if I could already city but
snow but you just said it you just said
that I would have more fun if this was
not my party and what is the thing that
you're anxious about how good of a time
who's having you are the people who are
there the people and but the default
disposition of a person who's at a party
is enjoyment
especially a good party so if you put
the ingredients in place and then it
just starts happening you look around
you're like these people having a good
time I'm gonna enjoy that I have been
thinking about this actually quite a bit
I've been thinking about what other
things could I engineer like other
experiences could i engineer for groups
of people maybe I should become a tour
guide because I've been thinking about
doing something special would like the
game night mm-hmm
and now that you know I can't do a party
like we did last year but like I neither
of us have ever thrown parties I haven't
had a birthday party I think the thing
that you're on two years I think the
thing that you're on is the last year
I'm like I want to do this again and
with the it's yeah it's more about
here's the thing about my personality
type that's different from yours is I'm
a perfectionist so I'm constantly
thinking not is this great but I have in
my mind what is the perfect party the
perfect party that I've planned right so
when it's okay for the last round of the
tournament like when the last two teams
are bowling and it and everyone I want
everyone else to gather around and when
the person's going to ball I'm gonna I'm
gonna get the DJ to kill the music and
it's gonna be comedic ly dramatic for
these amateur bowlers to feel like
they're in a freakin bowling tournament
that will be funny and it also be fun
for everybody to be to be focused on it
but then when the party goes along in
the freakin DJ's packin up and it's like
okay that can't happen you know these
are the things that start to go off in
my mind as a perfectionist that I think
it's healthy for me to come to grips
with of course and maybe that does mean
throwing more parties but no but I mean
and of course no one no one knows what
you want it right so it didn't bum me
out actively but subconsciously as a
perfectionist these things tend to stick
in your if you can find a way to in to
take a mental note next time I have a
bowling birthday party
I'm do it in a way so that we make sure
that the tournament is still going when
everybody's still there but right I'm
not gonna not enjoy this first one I
didn't hey you know I enjoyed it as much
as I could at this point in my life but
when I'm 50 I will enjoy it even more Oh
a couple of other side notes we also
planned the party on a Sunday night I I
think spare no expense to have a party
on a Friday or Saturday night yeah it's
my other thing because we rented out the
whole bowling alley and there was no way
we could have done that on a Saturday
and I think so there would have been
other people there on a Saturday but I
don't know if that made it would have
been a better choice or in general to
throw an epic party you can't do it on a
Sunday I have people worry a lot of a
lot of people got a they got to go
somewhere they can't be worrying about
their lives the next day other than that
I'm very I'm very happy with it it was a
great party
it was a really good party I mean Lionel
Richie would have really sent it over
the top but I'm fine with that joke that
doesn't hurt me because that wasn't part
of my plan
but Lionel's not he's not that
responsive he's just not that well I
know is not responsive well I trust us
yeah he's just he's got his own thing
been begging he's taking me here from LA
he's got his Lionel thing and that's
good you know we've got ours okay we're
gonna talk about getting old but so stay
tuned for that first we're gonna let you
know about some stuff that you can buy
well you can buy this kind candy randy's
t-shirt that I'm sporting but we've got
all types of good mythical summer stuff
we got the good mythical summer camp
shirt the rest about to hold up we got
the Dinka and sink it shirt brand-new to
the store got a mythical to got star
this is uh said I said the word got in
their mythical got star don't know
there's nothing go-to mythical dot store
this is the good mythical summer camp
t-shirt good mythical summer camp is not
something that actually exists yet but
it we do have a t-shirt that captures
the experience that one might have there
we've got the two of us
around a campfire they can see if
they're looking at it they can see it
they are looking at what but what about
oh they actually they can't see it there
you go out here see I was holding it
outside of the frame but yeah that's why
your desired thing is to not give you
the whole thing talk about it okay there
it is there we are
now we don't have to describe what's
happening cuz a you already have and be
there looking at okay it's not an actual
camp it's so sure it's so sorry more
camp that doesn't exist ring T here take
that one back to put that over there
thanks for supporting internat Ament and
wrapping your team which is team
mythical beast through the summer I will
say just one small one additional thing
that I don't give a flying F what they
say about turning 4040 is fabulous when
you're fortunate enough to have friends
like you
that's good that's good you should have
said that for reals
the only thing that kept me from
enjoying your party in the way that I
live like you can stop clapping now you
can come out we need to ball just party
this is not about me just have fun you
know it's not it's not about me is the
fact that when I got into the party like
literally walked in saw the food saw all
the bowling lanes was like I'm gonna
have such a good time yeah I made him up
made up my mind that I wasn't gonna
worry about the fact that the next day
was Monday that's it I don't care if
Monday's what I say but then my
beautiful wife comes up to me and says I
left my phone in the uber
but seriously yeah I was like oh gosh of
course I still have a phone so now I'm
responsible and for handling this and
also so you gotta solve this crisis you
gonna being in party mode use my app you
know so and also how does one get a
phone back great question it's not as
easy as one might think especially when
your driver does not speak English well
because you still had is now there was a
communication her number mister
assumptions so thanks for calling me
mister assumptions I kind of like it
i what did I do
oh you can click on help click on I lost
an item then it eventually puts you
through to this number that caused them
but it doesn't show what their number is
I don't really understand its basically
so that you can ruther system in the
right way they're supposed to get like a
fifteen dollar reward back or whatever
when they bring it back but this uber
driver did not understand the system and
did not really understand how that
worked and so when I got her on the
phone it took about ten minutes to just
explain that my phone is still in the
car my wife's phone is in the car
because she was charging it with one of
her dilly-dally x' and anyway i got it
back but it took like an hour and a half
so like the first hour and a half of
your party I was kind of dealing with
that and like having to go out into the
lobby to here be able to hear myself and
hear the the driver on the phone and
eventually she brought it back and then
when I went out I had sixteen dollars
cash now the thing said give $15 for a
returned item I had sixteen that's all
the cash I had on me I was like here's
her sixteen dollars us all I got and
then she was like 25 ooh and she was
holding the phone captive you're not in
a position to barter at this point
you could barter he give him a watch I
ran back in and just found the nearest
friend seriously
yeah warden Annie were there I was like
you guys got ten bucks yeah you got Ward
to give you ten bucks
daddy needs ten blocks I told him why
and they gave it to me oh wow yeah Oh
Annie ten bucks but or do you whenever
you go to give her that Tim bucks she's
gonna be like 25 bucks she said don't
worry about it anyway I got a phone back
start having a blast then I lost
actually I did okay you didn't lose the
tournament he got down to the last two
teams well again and half of one of the
teams had to have it in my part my team
was my wife and I and Stevie and her
girlfriend Cassie and I ended up talking
Tobias you know of buddy system Fame and
he's also been in a lot of other stuff
Tobias he came in and I was talking to
him about I was like I'm definitely not
gonna win my team Stevie and Cassie and
Jesse and me so I'm definitely not gonna
win but I didn't say all I told him was
like well I'm definitely not winning so
Tobias was talking to Stevie and they
were talking about the tournament he was
like all I know is Rhett said he's
definitely not gonna win and Stevie was
like Stevie and Cassie came out to me
and they were like oh we heard what you
were saying about your team well we
didn't win but then one couple that was
half of the four-person team who made it
to the finals had to leave early and
then Nick and Alison and then Nick came
up and was like hey you want to be on my
final team and then Ben's girlfriend
Jordan joined our team so I will point
out when you start recruiting people to
your to your final team you know
championship team you should have an
advantage to win it up TWEN the person
on the other team one of the four guys
is daven who works for us when he has
professional bowling shoes he brings his
own shoes but also say that I'm
not really good at bowling and neither
is Jordan we're just average so we have
a try to make it it was like okay we're
not gonna bring in like the best person
here any luck in an indian you lost by
six six and things it came down to the
last role which was pretty dramatic good
way to end the part what are the chances
that eight people's that four people
added up with four other people it comes
down to just six bits one hundred
percent I plant it that way oh good in
the party in the days following the
party you know I felt the need to
actively engage in reflection on my life
and the four teenis of myself now I have
to admit I did I felt in a little bit of
a funk after the thing you know it's
kind of cliche but I have kind of felt
that way I think um obviously I'm a
little too cerebral when it comes to my
own party I've got things I got to work
through but then beyond that you start
to think got all these friends here and
it's I wanted some blessed to be where
I'm at would and have all these people
that means so much to me and it's like
you started thinking weird things I'd
like how much do they really mean to me
you know you start to think weird things
like kind of depressed depressed
thoughts okay so I got anticipated that
was what you're gonna say I thought
you're gonna say you got you got all
these free together there for a party
but they're really just mourning the
death of the prime of your life like now
I can relate to that my point is I'm
seeing things that are totally unfounded
and it's at a point where I can be very
grateful and I'm typically very positive
I've been experiencing a little cloud of
negative introspection and over
analyzation so I'm trying I'm I'm on the
I'm on the I'm on the backside of that
now and so it now all I'm thinking about
because we've gotten through that is
just just the just the sheer symptoms of
getting older and it's not just the
grain of hair I'm glad I made the
decision to like let the gray hairs fly
you know it's it hasn't been a year yet
but
you know look at my age a little bit but
the thing that's getting me is not the
hair on my head but the hair in other
places I've started to shave weird spots
man like I've got I've got hair on my
shoulders like I got up I got this like
weird little community on the right
shoulder and the left shoulder and it
cuz when I'm like brushing my teeth in
them I'm like what is that a weird
community up there yeah I'm just gonna
I'm shaving my face I'm like I'll just
go down there shave that off a little
bit mmm got a little one over here she
waxes shave that one off over there
he'll the follicle man and I think this
is common because in the in that song
Amanda which there's a Don Williams
version there's a Waylon Jennings
version he says he talks about a look in
the mirror in total surprised to see the
hair on my shoulders in the age in my
eyes I'm like okay all right Waylon and
Don went through this I'm I'm in good
company I'll be okay but then I start
looking at my ears once you start you
just can't stand I'm like there's a
community of hair on my ears and I ain't
even talking about in my ears that's
what that's the common thing I'm talking
about the outer Ridge like right there
unlike the outer Ridge in my ear I got a
community of hair growing right there
you see it and so every few days I got
to hit that with a razor
yeah well thick it's hard not to Nick
your ear when shaving it with a razor
man you had to get your razor I feel
like a kid who's just going through
puberty and learning how to shave but
it's my ear but and also the inside like
I have nose trimmers that I shove in my
ears and I I've looked I've looked at
you on good mythical morning enough to
know that you got up you
a community coming out of your ears yeah
but here's the thing he's gotta be there
for a reason
oh you want to you want me to leave it
just letting that like like there must
be some survival benefit like when you
get so old there's a reason that old men
have hair in other places and I don't
and you know just because I don't
understand their survival benefit
doesn't doesn't mean that it doesn't
exist I don't want to get rid of it
because then I might die
it must be well when you get older you
am I kidding I also groom myself you
can't hear as well when you get old I so
I think it's your ears just closing
themselves up with hair it's like we
don't need these anymore we can't you
know the frequency fidelity is gone so
let's just close up shop and I think you
need some you need some some signs you
need to know I think know what you need
some in physical indications that you're
getting old well that's one yeah I'm
little red flags I'm not done with the
hair because oh yeah your wife told me
that you had some kind of egg which I my
egg I don't know she just told me that
she walked in and and you had some
little like handheld like egg shaped Oh
hanging it where you were running it
overall every part of your body not an
egg a peanut it's a you know a clipper a
peanut it's it there's there's a certain
type of clippers you know like hair
clippers you give someone a buzz cut
with well there's a smaller version made
by wall with an H not a sponsor called
the peanut it's a smaller Clippers that
all of the hairdresser's have and it's
just like it's easier for grooming like
your your body hair cuz it fits in weird
places
shave peanuts with it because it's
smaller yeah so yeah I've been using
that and yeah I for two years now I I'm
loud and proud that I trim all body hair
like my leg hair I like kiotas felt
light room doff but I wait so long I
trimmed out so much body hair I stand in
the shower
no water just so I can then gather it up
I gathered up enough body hair that I
that I peanut it off of myself it was
like it was like a the size of a human
brain like a hair I'm sure a big
compress into it much like a mouse brain
probably yeah I did I compressed it into
the mouse brain and then I wrapped it in
toilet paper and I put it in the not the
toilet and that's be a mistake
that's be as a mistake I put it in the
trash can but here's the last place that
I've noticed hair that gosh if this is
happening at 40 what's gonna happen at
50 you quit caring at 50 I've noticed
hairs on my nose
oh yeah the tip of the nose like here on
the bridge like not the bridge but like
just above the nostrils right in the
middle like a troll like a freaking
troll yeah and so I'm not shaving those
I'm plucking up no I pluck my eyebrows I
never got out of that since puberty so
now I'm like the the time of self-care
is just like it's just blooming man the
time makes you have the time it takes to
get all the hair off my body like I'm
freaking plucking hairs off the top of
my nose gives you purpose man that's
just as you get older you start you know
and this is the thing that I've been
that I've been contemplating and hold on
some of them are black you think they're
just little white hairs no I have a few
that are actually black what on earth
it's like I get the hairs on my hand
yeah there's white there's a reason
there's probably some sort of
sensitivity like when you get close to
things as an old person you need to know
that you're getting close to a wall and
the hairs on your nose touch it first
and you stopped short before you died
whiskers as I've been 44 months now
you're killing it - I I'm so much more
conscious of age so you know you know
how like when you've got like when
you're thinking about getting a new car
and then you start seeing that car
everywhere yeah or you start thinking
that you've got some sort of like a you
know we
we got a friend who was losing his hair
he was like I I'm thinking about it so I
I look at everyone's hair to see how
much hair they've got I'm gonna start
looking at people's and noses I never
thought about age in the way that I've
been thinking about it lately and I
think part of it is this this look this
whole question that I can't escape and
that's my best years behind me and I
know that that's a very cliche thing but
I especially and I'm a futurist that's
my disposition I'm always thinking about
what the next thing is and I've always
firmly believed that my best work is it
is that is ahead of me
right and I still feel that about what
we do right so I still have every reason
to believe that the most significant
thing we're going to create is something
we have yet to create and even if that's
utterly false it's very important to
believe it right but then I begin very
healthy to believe that I know that at
some point at some point it will become
irrational to believe that right okay at
some point yeah it becomes unlikely that
the thing that is gonna be the greatest
thing you've ever created is ahead of
you I still feel like it's it's rational
at this point but then I start thinking
well maybe it's not you know and again
this is pretty this is a pretty selfish
thing because your your life is not
boiled down to these things that you
create for your own self glorification
I'm aware of that and I'm aware of the
the you know then the what is the word
I'm looking for the psychology behind
your statement you mean just the fact
that this is not a healthy way to think
about things necessarily but that's the
thing I've been thinking about lately is
like you start noticing oh that guy is
younger than me like why why why am I
thinking that you know yeah when you
start we talked about this before how I
spent most of my life like thinking like
NBA players are older than me
and even we might become older than the
average NBA player you still see them as
older because you you you see them as
that's the motivation which you always
watch them but but now I definitely feel
older than them and I just find myself
thinking about age and then also
thinking about like I'm 40 and then I
started thinking man oh man as soon as
the summer's over there's like a couple
of months and then I'm 41 and that
happens so quickly and that's one year
out of 10 and then I'm and then that's
good
and then like these foot likes when he's
like I'm 41 years old and I ain't got no
place to go when it's over you know
great song by the way and I do take
comfort in the fact that it's one of
murrells best albums serving 90 proof 41
40 41 years old I think we've talked
about that I for me I'm I try to adopt
I'm staying with country music lyrics
for some reason and I'll stick with
Waylon here you know in in in the song
way Moore's blues he says I got my name
painted on my shirt I'm no ordinary dude
I ain't got to work you know just puts
it in perspective that like the song is
a blue song and he's like I mean he's
acknowledging his age especially when
you pair it with like the the song I
mentioned earlier about the hair on your
shoulders and dealing with that but like
the dude is live and life still wearing
you know it's in a mandate says I'm
crowding 30 or and then the lyrics and
some versions are also now I've turned
40 and I'm still wearing jeans you know
it's like I'm still I'm still a kid at
heart I'm still I'm still living this
dream life where I've got my own freakin
logo on my shirt is what Waylon was
singing you know it's like I ain't got
nothing to complain about even though I
may be over the hill
you know it's like few people can say
can walk around in jeans in their own
merch proudly right so I think that's
that's kind of how I tried it that's the
perspective I try to adopt is just one
of being grateful for what we've got and
for what we've already accomplished even
if that's it but it's not healthy just
just to rest on your laurels so I do
think it's good for us to believe our
best work is ahead of us but at some
point you just you just retire and
Spearfish well that that's another thing
is I mean obviously we're retirement is
nowhere in sight and no but I'm I'm
reading a book and then the main
character is recently retired and he
just sits and watches television in the
afternoon like watches like Judge Judy
and dr. Phil and his life has become
that but then something happens that
then kind of rien gauges him and what
his career was and it's a Stephen King
book yeah it's the it's the it's the
first it's the first in the the Mercedes
killer trilogy which I don't actually I
don't know if that's the name of it but
I can't remember the name of the book
but it's the it's that Mercedes killer
trilogy okay and um you know and this
guy's 62 in the book and I think about
how he didn't have anything so you
mentioned spearfishing I feel the need
to begin to introduce and again we have
some things that we do like what you
know but at least one of them is
something that would be is gonna be
difficult to do as you get older like I
mean the whole paddleboarding thing is
or at least paddle surfing and the way
that we do I mean as much as you've
alone been injured in the process of the
few times that we've been it's 60 you're
probably not gonna want to be willing
you're not gonna be willing to deal with
whatever the legal repercussions of
getting
is that why you're getting into golf
well it is one reason the Mac and I'm
going back into golf because my dad's
coming into town and I want to play with
him and I also want to get the boys into
it and especially Shepard cuz he didn't
really have anything that he's you know
sports wise that he's really into you
keep me a lot of money off a kid playing
golf I hear too late you got to start
him in there like one but anyway but you
thought but this the idea of you know I
heard Joe Rogan say one time that
everybody needs you got to have
something that you wake up to do and
right now we go and I don't that that
sounds true good as a general statement
I think it probably is more true of some
people than other people so but but in
general I do think that's true of us
well specifically I think this I would
say most people need something in one
form or another yeah I mean but that
could be read the paper I'm just saying
that like yeah once you stop having
something to wake up and do and so and
and so that's when I start getting
really self-conscious about like what
we've created I'm of course we have we
would I think we've talked about this
we've maybe we haven't but we have a
chip on our shoulder in some regards
when it comes to our work and what we've
done because you know everything that
we've done is kind of lived under this
in the world of YouTube and this is
probably an unreasonable thing to think
but there is a certain connotation that
comes along with the word youtuber and
the stuff that youtubers do and it's
because it's such a broad category and
something that anybody can do you know
when we talk to people in the industry
about some other ideas that we have that
may transcend YouTube and maybe
something like a TV show or a movie or
something like that
even though there's not really that much
of a distinction anymore between these
different media's you know for instance
buddy system was not even reviewed nope
not one critic wrote a review of buddy
system nobody cared about our show on
you
red because nobody cared about YouTube
red at the time I cared and you know and
so there's a chip on our shoulder that
we want to create something that people
can't help but encounter even if they
hate it but people have to encounter and
have to have to talk about it but but
then I started thinking okay but what at
what point am I too old to be able to
create that and to be able to get people
to care about it because I started
thinking well people don't really know
there were 40 that's the best thing
we've got going for us is they still see
us as these go like I don't know how old
they are but those guys from YouTube
they seem young and they're on YouTube
so they must be young come on Bo the one
with glasses he's got great and so you
start you start second-guessing I think
that's that's what I've been dealing
with and again I recognize that it's not
this is not a healthy way to think
because the other thing that I'm trying
to do just like personally is get to a
place where I don't care about what
people think and I don't care about and
I don't people and I don't evaluate
myself through the lens of what people
think about my accomplishments or
creating something that then is you're
satisfied that it now defines you you
know in a way that you want to be
defined you know I I'm definitely
thinking more about it I think you know
when I'm when I mentioned earlier that
like I just feel like I've I've been
Italy I don't I guess you'd call it a
depression like if it's like a few days
stint like for the past week or so the
one missing piece of the puzzle which I
certainly is a huge factor in all this
was I had to fly home right before the
party the the two days leading up to the
party I had a shocking death in the
family my uncle passed away it was a a
tragic accident on his farm it was
utterly shocking to our entire family so
like
we knew we all flew home for that he he
he was 69 years old he was retired you
know he was he was doing what he loved
I mean it's not a joke but he died doing
what he loved he was on his tractor
mm-hm
on his on his own land that he that his
his grandparents farmed his parents farm
he farmed and his son farms any other
way that's how he went out he made the
decision to stop doing his he could have
kept working at his other job sure but
he made a decision to cuz he wanted it
farm so that was what he that was why he
got up every day but it was an
uncertainly an untimely and shocking end
to his life you know I I thought we were
gonna have to cancel the party because I
didn't you know we weren't gonna we were
gonna be there for the family and then
get back whenever it made sense and then
it worked out but it was literally we
flew back in that morning a night we're
having a party so I think the day after
the party and the day since it's not you
know all those things together for me
have you know you when you talk have led
to a lot of introspection and reflection
I think that we talked about being over
the hill but it there's an underlying
assumption if you listen to a lot of
what we said in this whole conversation
it's just assumption that what's the
average age yeah because I'm gonna beat
that or I'm at least gonna hit that you
know I'm gonna live to 79 and then it's
you know there's of course no guarantee
that that's gonna happen you know and so
it's I I think that I certainly don't
think about and it would drive me nuts
if I if I woke up every morning I
thought this could be my last there was
the guy you know the old guy with the
beard who worked on like the the
pyrotechnic stuff for GM him like when
we did the fireball in his stuff he had
that catchphrase when we'd see him and
for we were like
hey man glad to see you again I cook I
can't remember his name and he would
always say I woke up alive now it's up
to me yeah you know it's like I woke up
alive
now it's up to me he's so it's like and
that me I mean and not just any maybe he
had him he is a pyro technician maybe
he's had some close calls but also an
older guy yeah I would I mean he could I
mean dude looked in his 70s it could be
that old yeah but um I guess he adopted
this mantra you think it's a healthy
mantra maybe it is when you're that age
like it at 40 years old I don't want to
wake up everyone and say this could be
my last day because I think that would
freaking wig me out but I think it in
there is there's got to be a way for
some of that perspective to influence
kind of what you're saying about being
so focused on what is it we're gonna
create that's gonna provide legitimacy
yeah or what you know I don't you you
don't know what early healthy what
caused it the thing that I struggle with
is is I mean this is like the thing that
I think about all the time is another
one of my mini personality defects is
just how much I want to how much I want
to accomplish right mm-hmm for those of
you who know the Enneagram I'm a three
on the Enneagram which is an achiever
and it just basically means that I'm
hyper competitive anybody who's watch
the show knows that I want to win I want
to be the best I want to create things
that people notice and while that's been
helpful and then be commended for it and
yeah yeah that's how that's how I want
basically it's how do you want to be
loved and so the way that I want to be
loved is by people loving the things
that I create and so I'll get
uncomfortable if you start talking
directly about me I'd rather you talk
about something that I created so the
but the struggle is is that I I'm like
okay I don't want to care about
accomplishing things
I don't care I want to accomplish
anything so I gotta get on this the end
in this loop because I'm like ah yeah I
guess there is some state of contentment
that like you know like a monk somewhere
has where they're like my my work is
this simple repetitive thing that I do
in the whole point and being a monk is
to kind of take away the things that
distinguish you as yourself you know
that's why you shave your head and
that's why you wear the same thing that
everybody does that's why you do the
same thing that everybody does that's
why you there's there's no hierarchy
you're not like he's the head he's the
head monk it's like everybody becomes
equal and you kind of fade into humanity
and I know that that's healthy in a lot
of ways but it also scares the crap out
of me so I think about like you know you
really don't look great with shaped yeah
and I think we couldn't have a beard
probably - it'd be horrible what's the
main reason I'm not a monk but but the
hood the big hoods but the I just
simultaneously looking to the future in
being like there's so many things that I
want to see us accomplish and to me it's
not about losing the desire to
accomplish those things it's losing the
false belief that I'm gonna find some
kind of purpose or ultimate satisfaction
in those things going well because we
have had a lot of success we've had a
lot of things go well and we know just
like we talked about in the book of
mythicality and the stop and celebrate
chapter that our mo is to accomplish
something and then immediately move on
to the next thing without stopping and
really appreciating it so I know that if
okay we've officially
people that critics care about it I can
anticipate what that feeling is going to
be I know that there's not true
satisfaction in that but if I can just
enjoy the process which is something
that I do enjoy the creative process is
like that's what we're made to do I find
incredible satisfaction not just in the
results but in the process I don't know
those are just the things that are kind
of running through my mind and the thing
that's complex
it is this age factor is the fact that
oh now I've got this other thing I've
got to contend with which is the fact
that it you know saying winning out of
the hourglass win is my yeah what am I
gonna run out of time when am I gonna
become irrelevant because I'm seeing I
seem too old when I might lose my mind
not gonna be a short what am I not gonna
have that thing all the best athletes in
the world even the best poker players in
the world are young guns right you don't
see some 45 year old come in there and
win the World Poker Tour you see a 20
year old do it I'm know there are
exceptions but that's how you feel
because what do they have did I have it
I lost it those are the those are the
things rattling around him in my 40 year
old mind I'm trying to figure out how
for me as a perfectionist as a
personality type how I'm interacting
with getting older because you know I
want things whether it's a party or
whatever it is my life to be arranged in
a certain way you know and I think you
might my uncle he was I think he also
might have been a one just like me a you
know a perfectionist because he said he
had his life arranged and even is his
family life in his professional life and
his hobby life he had it all very
arranged and he was very he's very
methodical and calculated which by the
way was why it was such a shock that he
had an accident it's totally against
everything that you've ever observed
from this guy and you know he I think he
was living that yet OOP it was over you
know and was it worth it was it worth
the you know is that is that the goal
for me is that what I'm trying to
emulate or is that something I'm trying
to I don't think so
you know I think it's something I'm
trying to put in its place
those
the strengths / weaknesses of being of
thinking I know the best way for
everything putting that in its place so
that I can still live a full life even
when things don't meet up meet meet my
standard which is probably if it is
attainable you have to sacrifice enough
things that it may not in general have
been worth it
you know in terms of like what that does
to relationships or you know what it
takes to get there
you know so using the party again as
analogy it's saying I think I did pretty
decent saying this was this was a
milestone experience that I'm grateful
that Christy and you encouraged us to do
to have the frickin party and not say
well because it can't be the absolute
perfect thing then I'm not gonna do it
that that would have been a been a
horrible mistake right and I think
that's uh I think that's a kind of a
microcosm of what I'm trying to do with
my life by putting put in those aspects
of my personality in their place so that
I can experience the imperfections of
life and see beauty in that and
experience that and loved and loved
throws yeah it's there loving there the
last thing I'll say which I which I
think is I don't know if it's a
generational thing I think we're the
same generation by the way so it's not
don't start treat me like a child
we're or whatever but it's between
there's a very small generation as
between Generation X and Millennials
mm-hmm the zinnia 'ls so what it's
called I think we're zinnias perennials
it's like 77 to 83 okay again this is
just stuff reporters make up so
take it with a grain of salt but the
thing I've been I think is is typical of
most generations before ours and mate
and maybe it still is I don't know is
that you tend to get a little calcified
in your in your views right you get to a
certain point and you're kind of like
I'm kind of done changing the way I
think about things so far in my life the
way that I view the world has has gone
through some very very drastic upheavals
and changes and you know I'm less
certain about very a whole host of
things and I ever was when I was 20
years old yeah when I was 20 I had just
a very particular understanding of so
many things and I was so sure that I was
right I mean it was just like I remember
sitting around and actually having the
the thought of like I pretty much think
I know the right thing about the most
important things yeah I was there for
that you know I was like I think I I
think I understand the basics of the
most important truths of the universe
mm-hmm that's a very fortunate position
to be in
I said to myself I did not actually say
this out loud but I remember like having
thoughts like that and then over the
past 20 years I've I look back at that
20 year old and I'm like what an idiot
you know I mean no no I was that's not
even let's not even keep it in the 20s
because you know I'll say it is
something that has we both it's part of
both of our experiences it's not
something that just you know shortly
after that we checked out of it's been
quite it's been quite a process between
20 and 40 it continues to this day I
mean and that's a weird place to be to
feel like you are
you entering into your 40s now there's a
lot there is a lot of stability there
there's a lot of stability in my life
you know with even the the the sort of
the unpredictable nature of what we do
as a career there's a lot of stability
and what we've yeah kind of kind of
built up and that stability has
increased exponentially just in the past
five years in a way that it did not
there was a lot of uncertainty there's
still a whole lot of uncertainty but
there's also there's a there's a
reasonable certainty that we're gonna be
okay we don't know exactly what our job
is going to look like five years from
now but probably gonna be okay you all
be not gonna be like thumbing down the
road you know what I mean unless it
makes for a good video or as a character
but I've never been less certain about a
lot of different things and more open to
like different people's perspectives and
like can hear somebody say something and
be like ah that's a that is uh that's a
good point yeah that's a good point
as well this is difficult to parse and I
think that that is in some ways that is
just I think that this next generation
like our kids are growing up in the
midst of that we kind of grew up in a
place where you were not exposed to
anything that challenged your worldview
and it was it was very tight and it was
very tidy and then we were kind of this
generation that got introduced through
the internet to all kinds of different
thoughts about different things and it
began to kind of change the way we
thought about that foundation but I
think that our children made it which
made our initial reaction to it
something that was more about
maintaining the tidiness in the in the
fact in the face of the internet
basically that now that matters asses
whereas our kids you know you there are
no hat wait when you grow up in an
environment we where's no way to not be
exposed to almost everything on earth
just just by virtue of the Internet as
much as you know you
you put up healthy boundaries and things
like that yeah absolutely it's a
different it's a different world though
he's now too old
yeah but it's uh what are you getting at
are you get maybe you're getting that
I'm just saying it's another observation
I made about myself the one thing that
we the one thing that we can have that
that 20-year old poker player can't have
is wisdom now
you don't automatically have it and I'm
not saying that we have it but i but I
aspire to that and that is something
that that is the advantage that old
farts can have right yeah and and I'm
all and I'm also trying to fight I'm
trying to fight cynicism actively you
know I hated fortnight I hear Locke talk
about the the latest little rapper you
know there's these little rappers
everybody's got little in front of their
name and I just found my find myself
just talking to him about how ridiculous
this whole thing is and and it probably
is ridiculous on some degree but this is
coming from a man who has regularly
eating animal testicles for
entertainment on the internet so I'm a
little ridiculous myself a little
ridiculous is my rap name but yeah again
I don't have a I don't have a conclusion
I don't have a landing place for this
it's just well I have to end it somehow
there are multiple things happening
there's this this internal struggle with
like trying to not be defined by my
accomplishments but being fearful that
I've yet to accomplish that maybe I've
accomplished the greatest thing I'm ever
going to accomplish this less certain
than I've ever been and then wanting to
fight against cynicism and just
beginning to say things like sometimes
just to be like you're talking up you
you're literally saying this generation
of kids like just don't use that
terminology don't get to a place where
you use the term this generation of
children or this generation of teenagers
and then say something negative because
that generation of teenagers in the way
they think differently in the things
that you know that frustrate us are
gonna be the things that pop most likely
to the positive things that define the
the world just it's the way it happens
man and it's happening quicker than ever
more quickly grammar nazis so now what I
think we just died now just curl up I
think we do everything we can to make it
a seventy nine point seven four and then
we die Buck Owens died in his sleep good
for him you know he finished a concert
in a in the Crystal Palace that he built
in Bakersfield and he went back to his
house and died in his sleep but there's
no guarantees I just wanted to tie in
another country music it's like it seems
like country music is my religion in
this episode so I just wanted to tie
that tie a bow on that but thanks for
listening in on this therapy session I
feel okay
don't you know I I always feel like in
like retrospect like looking at what
we've discussed in this episode I do
feel the need as we're shutting this
thing down to just say I don't think you
need to worry about me you know it's
like I used the term you need to worry
about me I think we've been very honest
about what we're doing but you know and
I want to be since event and throwing
around the term depression which I I
know I said that a few times but
experiencing depression I don't know
what I want to say about it except it
what do you think I should say about it
I just don't want people to worry about
me in that way specifically because
you're not that's not I'm not actively
working with clinical clinical
depression but many many many people are
absolutely and hopefully we have it I
mean we you know we did what we always
do we started talking about something
not knowing where it's gonna go I think
ultimately what you're saying is that
don't I mean we're just processing these
things it's like don't and I don't think
there's anything wrong I'm not gonna
apologize for being sad obviously but I
you know so I'm what we're not trying to
be an example but in retrospect if we
were an example with anything I hope is
that that we're talking openly and
honestly with each other you just happen
to be listening at a certain point I
think that's what happened in this
episode and I well there's a podcast
that Jesse's begun listening to that is
a therapist and her patients and they
let you listen in on the sessions really
and I don't you know obviously all the
confidentiality stuff is taken care of
but well this is as close as we're gonna
get to that so thanks for listening in
and we'll talk out you next week yes
[Music]